only a third of the country is voting
only a third of the country is voting we
haven't played a clip of the view in a
while so it's just some crazy woman
screaming on The View goodbye there's a
lot of people that don't understand
what's going on you guys we there's a
group of us that don't go talk to the
manager you know what I'm saying like
there's a group of us that that'll be
like no manager come over here this
didn't taste good but there's a lot of
us that'll be like I'm just not going to
come back here no more we need to start
talking to the manager yeah do you
understand yeah pay attention only a
third of this country is voting only a
third of the country is voting only a
third of the country is voting and you
don't shy away from politics you follow
politics closely and you'll hit either
side what made you want to work that
more into your humor in the last few
years well honestly because I just
learned about it when I went to SNL okay
before SNL like new just New York period
you guys are really smart about politics
and stuff like y'all really are on that
like California we over there smoking
weed you know that swimming pool sunton
we ain't really into it right so when
when I got to SNL there was so many
things that I learned about that I
didn't even know like seriously the
electorial college I didn't know about
that I was just don't I know you're
going to be mad when I say this I did
think it was a college College I
thought you go the Electoral col I
thought that that you know the the
people got to go there before they
become a politician oh I wish that were
the case listen the people voting for
Trump should go to call exactly exactly
so that's that's things like that to
learn all that type of
stuff